This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For many people, this is what work sounds like nowadays. It's a constant thrum of notifications, tweets and messages. Each time we respond to an email or a text or Google a question that's just popped into our head, we pay a small price. In the moment, this price is imperceptible. But over time, it adds up. And we haven't quite come to terms with a cost of constant distractions.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。对许多人来说，这就是当今工作的声音。它是通知、推文和消息的持续嗡嗡声。每当我们回复一封电子邮件或一条短信，或者搜索一个刚刚出现在脑海中的问题时，我们都要付出一点代价。在当下，这种代价是难以察觉的。但随着时间的推移，它会累积起来。而我们还没有完全意识到持续分心的代价。
We treat it, I think, in this more general sense of it, I probably should be less distracted. And I think it's more urgent than people realize. In the third episode of our Work 2.0 series, we revisit a favorite conversation from 2017 to explore questions many of us struggle with on a daily basis. What are modern-day jobs doing to our minds? Why is it so hard to cultivate focus? And what would it look like to transform our jobs so that we can engage in deeper, more meaningful work?
我认为，我们以一种更普遍的意义来对待它，即我可能应该减少分心。而且我认为这比人们意识到的更为紧迫。在我们“工作 2.0”系列的第三集中，我们重温了 2017 年的一次精彩对话，探讨了我们许多人每天都在挣扎的问题。现代工作对我们的思想有什么影响？为什么培养专注力如此困难？如果我们改变工作方式，以便能够从事更深入、更有意义的工作，那会是什么样子？
People who spend a larger proportion of the professional time concentrating intensely on a single target, tend to enjoy their work a lot more. There's a lot of different factors about why that might be true, but I ended by saying that deep life is a good life. How deep work can change our jobs and our lives, this week on Hidden Brain. Cal Newport is a computer science professor at Georgetown University. You might expect a professor of computer science to be tethered to his computer and all the latest devices. But that's not Cal. He's deliberately sought to break away from the distractions of modern technology, and
那些将大部分专业时间集中在单一目标上的人，往往会从工作中获得更多的乐趣。关于为什么会这样，有很多不同的因素，但我最后说的是，深度生活是美好的生活。深度工作如何改变我们的工作和生活，本周《Hidden Brain》为您呈现。卡尔·纽波特是乔治城大学的计算机科学教授。你可能认为一位计算机科学教授会整天守着电脑和各种最新设备。但卡尔不是这样。他刻意寻求摆脱现代科技的干扰，并且
he's trying to get the rest of us to follow his lead. Cal is the author of Deep Work, Rules for Focus Success in a Distracted World. Cal Newport, welcome to Hidden Brain. Well, thanks for having me on. You talk on your book about several highly influential thinkers, people like the psychiatrist Carl Jung, the writer's Mark Twain, Jakey Rowling, and you see they all have a set of habits that are quite striking in terms of how they're able to get great work done. This was something I noticed was very common to influential thinkers is that they all seem to have this
他正试图让其他人也跟随他的脚步。卡尔是《深度工作：在分心世界中获得卓越成就的法则》一书的作者。卡尔·纽波特，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我。你在书中谈到了几位极具影响力的思想家，比如精神病学家卡尔·荣格，作家马克·吐温、J.K.罗琳，你认为他们都有一套非常引人注目的习惯，使他们能够完成伟大的工作。这是我注意到在有影响力的思想家中非常普遍的一点，那就是他们似乎都有这种
drive to on a regular basis, cut themselves off from their lives of busyness and communication and distraction, and isolate themselves to think deeply. What do they do specifically? Well, what you'll notice is that they often will have a location, a separate location they go to when they go to when they want to think deeply. That's often cut off from the rest of their life. So Carl Jung would go out to the Bollinger Tower, a stone house without electricity or running
动力，定期将自己从忙碌、沟通和分心的生活中隔绝出来，并孤立自己进行深入思考。他们具体做了什么？嗯，你会注意到他们通常会有一个地点，一个他们想要深入思考时会去的独立地点。这通常与他们的日常生活隔绝。所以卡尔·荣格会去博林根塔，那是一座没有电或自来水的石屋。
water. He built by the lake side outside of a small village in the countryside beyond Zurich. JK Rowling, when she was struggling to finish to Deathly Hallows, rented out this big suite at the Balmour hotel next to the big castle in downtown Edinburgh, where she'd go and just think Harry Potter style thoughts. Mark Twain had a cabin for a long period of his life. He would go to on the property of their house. It was so far from the house that his family had to blow a horn to try to catch his attention
他在苏黎世郊外的一个小村庄旁的湖边建造了它。J.K.罗琳在努力完成《死亡圣器》时，租下了爱丁堡市中心大城堡旁巴尔莫勒尔酒店的一个大套房，她会在那里思考哈利·波特式的想法。马克·吐温在他人生的很长一段时间里都有一个小木屋。他会去自家房产里的那个小木屋。它离房子太远了，以至于他的家人不得不吹号角来引起他的注意，
to let him know that dinner was ready. They go somewhere physically isolated and different where they can without distraction think deeply. What does work look like for the rest of us? When you look at the average American worker for example, are most of us doing this kind of deep, sustained work? The type of deep work I talk about is almost non-existent as far as I can tell and most knowledge work positions. Even when people think that they're single-tasking, they say, I've learned a lesson that I'm not supposed to multitask,
告诉他晚餐准备好了。他们去了一个物理上孤立且不同的地方，在那里他们可以不受干扰地深入思考。对我们其他人来说，工作是什么样的？例如，当你观察普通的美国工人时，我们大多数人是否在做这种深入、持续的工作？据我所知，我所谈论的那种深度工作在大多数知识型工作岗位中几乎是不存在的。即使人们认为他们是在进行单任务处理，他们说，我已经吸取了教训，我不应该进行多任务处理，
I'm not supposed to be on the phone and do email, while I write, I'm just working on one thing at a time. What they're still doing is every five or 10 minutes, a just check, let me just check to my me just do a just check to my inbox. Let me just do a just check to my phone real quick and then back to my work. And it feels like single tasking. It feels like you're predominantly working on one thing.
我不应该在写作时打电话和处理电子邮件，我一次只做一件事。但他们仍然在做的是，每隔五到十分钟，就检查一下，让我检查一下我的收件箱。让我快速检查一下我的手机，然后回到我的工作中。这感觉像是单任务处理。感觉你主要是在做一件事。
But even those very brief checks that switch your context even briefly can have this massive negative impact on your cognitive performance, is to switch itself that hurts, not how long you actually switch. So I actually think even very conscientious knowledge workers who think they're pretty good at focusing on one thing at a time are actually still working far
但即使是那些非常短暂的检查，也会改变你的语境，即使是短暂的，也会对你的认知表现产生巨大的负面影响，是切换本身造成了伤害，而不是你切换了多久。所以我实际上认为，即使是非常认真的知识工作者，他们认为自己很擅长一次专注于一件事，实际上仍然远未达到
from the sort of high performance, deep work ideal. What is the evidence that the switching causes harm to the quality of your thinking? Well, we've seen the show up in different types of scientific studies and from different types of perspectives. I think one angle that makes it pretty clear is to work that Professor Sophie Leroy has done on an effect called attention residue. This is actually something that's pretty easy to isolate in the laboratory.
那种高性能、深度工作的理想状态。有什么证据表明切换会损害你的思维质量？嗯，我们已经在不同类型的科学研究和不同的视角中看到了这一点。我认为一个让这一点变得非常清楚的角度是索菲·勒鲁瓦教授在一种称为“注意力残留”的效应上所做的工作。这实际上是在实验室中很容易分离出来的东西。
You essentially give a subject something cognitively demanding to do that you can measure, like trying to solve hard puzzles. And then at some point, you distract them briefly as the experimenter, have them look at something else, change their context very briefly. When they then turn back to the original, cognitively demanding task, you see the performance drops. And it drops for a while. It takes a while for this attention residue to clear out. And this is essentially what we're doing to ourselves when we do that quick glance at the inbox or to the phone. Callum wondering, do you think most of us are aware
你基本上给受试者一些需要认知能力的任务，你可以测量这些任务，比如尝试解决难题。然后，作为实验者，你在某个时刻短暂地分散他们的注意力，让他们看别的东西，非常短暂地改变他们的语境。当他们随后回到最初的、需要认知能力的任务时，你会发现表现下降了。而且下降持续了一段时间。这种注意力残留需要一段时间才能清除。而这基本上就是我们在快速浏览收件箱或手机时对自己所做的事情。卡尔，我想知道，你认为我们大多数人是否意识到
of the costs of distraction in our lives? People, I think, intuit that they're too distracted and it's making them feel fragmented and exhausted and anxious, but we treat it, I think, in this more general sense of, I probably should be less distracted. And I think it's more urgent than people realize that if your brain is how you make a living, then you really have to worry about this cognitive fitness.
生活中分心的代价？我认为，人们直觉上感到自己太分心了，这让他们感到支离破碎、精疲力竭和焦虑，但我们以一种更普遍的意义来对待它，即我可能应该减少分心。而且我认为这比人们意识到的更为紧迫，如果你的大脑是你谋生的工具，那么你真的必须担心这种认知健康。
I mean, how are you getting performance out of your brain? Are you taking care to get good performance out of your brain or not? And people would probably be surprised the more they think about it, how much they're leaving on the table by the way they're currently working right now much they're leaving on the table by the way They're currently working right now. Does it matter that most of us are not trying to win a Nobel Prize or
我的意思是，你是如何从你的大脑中获得表现的？你是否在注意从你的大脑中获得良好的表现？人们如果多思考一下，可能会感到惊讶，他们目前的工作方式让他们损失了多少。他们目前的工作方式让他们损失了多少。我们大多数人不是为了赢得诺贝尔奖或
You know a Pulitzer Prize that we're not necessarily genius Is does it actually matter for most of us that we don't regularly put ourselves in a state of deep work? Well, this is a big shift that I think has happened in our economy because it's an increasing portion of our economy that are essentially making a living by using their brain to process information and produce new information. And even if you're not trying to write great literature or solve a great theorem, if you're using your brain primarily to produce value, be it writing, marketing, copy, or putting together a new plan for your business startup-up. These type of things matter.
普利策奖，我们不一定是天才，这重要吗？我们不经常让自己处于深度工作状态，这对我们大多数人来说真的重要吗？嗯，我认为我们的经济中发生了一个巨大的转变，因为我们经济中越来越多的部分基本上是通过使用大脑来处理信息和产生新信息来谋生的。即使你不是试图写出伟大的文学作品或解决伟大的定理，如果你主要使用大脑来产生价值，无论是写作、营销文案，还是为你的商业初创公司制定新计划。这些事情都很重要。
The human brain has become one of the main capital resources in our economy. It's what in the knowledge economy we spend most of our money on is supporting human brains to process things and produce value. So we should care. I think the ability to deep work would be relevant to the professional success of almost everyone in the knowledge work field, which is a huge part of our economy. I'd like to run a little thought experiment. Imagine we're following a doctor as she's making the rounds of a hospital and she's looking
人类大脑已成为我们经济中的主要资本资源之一。在知识经济中，我们大部分资金都花在支持人类大脑处理事物和产生价值上。所以我们应该关心。我认为深度工作的能力与知识工作领域中几乎每个人的职业成功都相关，这是我们经济中很大的一部分。我想做一个小小的思想实验。想象一下，我们跟随一位医生在医院查房，她正在观察
at many patients and presumably the patients all present with different problems and complications and so forth. And I think what we would expect is for this doctor to very quickly flip from one subject, one topic, one patient to the next. That if we, if the doctor were to say, you know, I can only do my best work. If I can focus on one patient, deeply understand that case, spend a lot of time with it. Yes, that might be true, but it's going to come at a cost, which is all the other patients
许多病人，据推测，病人们都表现出不同的问题和并发症等等。我认为我们所期望的是这位医生非常迅速地从一个主题、一个话题、一个病人切换到下一个。如果医生说，你知道，我只有在能专注于一个病人，深入了解那个病例，花很多时间在上面时，才能做到最好。是的，这可能是真的，但这将付出代价，那就是所有其他病人
that the doctor is not going to see. What are the costs of deep work? Well, where I'd want to get with the doctor is not going to see, what are the costs of deep work? Well, where I'd want to get with the doctor is just the ability, even if you're relatively briefly staying with each patient, to actually be able to stay just with that patient. So a case study I uncovered actually after the book came out was of two different groups at the same elite level residency. One group had a culture of email. So, hey, I need something here's a question, what about this patient, and they're expected that the constantly be available
医生将无法看到。深度工作的代价是什么？嗯，我想和医生探讨的不是她看不到什么，深度工作的代价是什么？嗯，我想和医生探讨的只是这种能力，即使你与每个病人相处的时间相对较短，也能真正做到只专注于那个病人。所以我发现的一个案例研究，实际上是在书出版后，是关于同一精英住院医师项目的两组人。一组有电子邮件文化。所以，嘿，我需要什么，这里有个问题，这个病人怎么样，他们被期望随时可以通过电子邮件联系到，
by email, the other group consolidated that type of administrative or logistical conversations to set meetings. And what the doctor from that hospital told me is that they had a real hard time keeping people in that first group, where in the second group group people were much happier. So deep work doesn't necessarily mean I can sit half a day
另一组将那种行政或后勤对话整合到设定的会议中。那位医生告诉我，第一组的人很难留住，而第二组的人要快乐得多。所以深度工作并不一定意味着我可以坐半天
and just think about this one patient, but just the ability to walk into a room and just think about that patient and not have to see 16 emails as you walk into the next room and have that eating away at your attention, that can really make a big difference. You said that the people who were engaged in deep work ended up being happier, so it's not just a question of being more productive, but you're making the case that deep work
只思考这一个病人，但仅仅是走进一个房间，只思考那个病人，而不必在走进下一个房间时看到 16 封电子邮件，并让它们蚕食你的注意力，这真的能产生很大的不同。你说那些从事深度工作的人最终更快乐，所以这不仅仅是一个更有效率的问题，你是在论证深度工作
produces a kind of intrinsic reward that doesn't come from being distracted? It seems to, and in fact, this caught me off guard when I was researching my book. I ended up adding a chapter to the book that was not in the original proposal. That was all about these findings. I kept coming across in these stories. I kept coming across about deep living, also just being good living. People who spend a larger proportion of the professional time concentrating intensely on a single high skill or high craft target, tend to enjoy their work a lot more.
产生了一种不会因分心而产生的内在奖励？似乎确实如此，事实上，当我在研究我的书时，这让我措手不及。我最终在书中增加了一个原始提案中没有的章节。那全是关于这些发现的。我在这些故事中不断遇到这些发现。我不断遇到关于深度生活，也就是美好生活。那些将大部分专业时间集中在单一高技能或高工艺目标上的人，往往会从工作中获得更多的乐趣。
And there's a lot of different factors about why that might be true, but I ended by saying a deep life is a good life. And that's something I really believe in. It can take a knowledge work career and make it much more satisfying than being in a persistent state of putting out fires and busy distraction.
关于为什么会这样，有很多不同的因素，但我最后说的是，深度生活是美好的生活。这是我真正相信的东西。它可以让知识工作生涯变得比处于持续的救火和忙碌分心状态中要满足得多。
Can you cite any professions where deep work is probably not called for and might even be a problem? Sure. There's plenty of examples I think where DeepWork is probably not that relevant. A couple of the common examples I give is actually I think being a CEO of a large company, you're probably going to better serve your company or stockholders by being a decision engine. For other people who are doing deep work, someone who people can come to, okay, what about this?
你能列举一些可能不需要深度工作，甚至可能是一个问题的职业吗？当然。我认为有很多例子说明深度工作可能并不那么相关。我给出的几个常见例子实际上是，我认为作为一家大公司的首席执行官，你可能通过成为决策引擎来更好地服务于你的公司或股东。对于其他人，那些正在进行深度工作的人，有人可以来找他们，好吧，这个怎么样？
What should we do here? You can be a consistent source of the vision and push these decisions in a consistent way. Another example is, let's say you're in what they would call here in DC, government relations, where really most of what you do is context and connections and connecting the right people to the right other people and keeping up with what's going on in people's lives. That's another example of a place where long solitary concentration is not going to make a difference. I think there's plenty of jobs, in other words, in which deep work doesn't make a difference. But I've also found, in my experience, that the number of jobs for which this is true is smaller than people expect. You make the argument in the book that there are lots of blue collar jobs, jobs where you're
我们在这里应该做什么？你可以成为愿景的一致来源，并以一致的方式推动这些决策。另一个例子是，假设你从事的是在华盛顿所说的政府关系工作，你所做的大部分工作实际上是语境、联系、将合适的人与合适的人联系起来，并跟上人们生活中发生的事情。这是另一个长期孤独的专注不会产生影响的例子。换句话说，我认为有很多工作，深度工作不会产生影响。但根据我的经验，我也发现，这种情况适用的工作数量比人们预期的要少。你在书中提出了一个论点，即有很多蓝领工作，那些你需要
working with your hands, where deep work actually produces much better work and also produces much better engagement with the work. Right, I think the connection between concentration and craft is actually clearer in a lot of these fields. If you talk to a craftsman, they will tell you immediately. Well, obviously, obviously you need to focus intensely, otherwise you're going to make a mistake. You're not going to produce the best quality work. You're going to get feedback immediately that you are less effective if you're more distracted. And a big part of the argument I'm making is that there's nothing different enough about a world that takes place on screens for this no longer to be true.
用手工作的工作，深度工作实际上会产生更好的工作，也会产生更好的工作参与度。是的，我认为专注与工艺之间的联系在许多这些领域实际上更清晰。如果你和工匠交谈，他们会立即告诉你。嗯，显然，显然你需要高度专注，否则你会犯错。你不会产生最高质量的工作。如果你更分心，你会立即得到反馈，证明你的效率较低。我所提出的论点的一个重要部分是，发生在屏幕上的世界并没有什么不同，以至于这一点不再适用。
So if you talk to true craftsmen, they already know the power of deep work. And so in some sense, we're just taking this message and bringing it up the speed for the 21st century. It seems to me that there are connections here with ideas related to mindfulness or ideas related to flow that you should be in the moment focused on what you're doing. It seems to me that those ideas are intimately connected with deep work. They are connected. So deep work can induce flow states, which is one of the reasons why people find a career
所以如果你和真正的工匠交谈，他们已经知道深度工作的力量。因此，在某种意义上，我们只是在获取这个信息，并将其提升到 21 世纪的速度。在我看来，这里与正念相关的想法或与心流相关的想法有联系，即你应该专注于你正在做的事情。在我看来，这些想法与深度工作密切相关。它们是相关的。所以深度工作可以诱发心流状态，这也是为什么人们发现职业
push more towards deep work is more satisfying. It's not entirely synonymous with flow. We know there's other types of states that also count as deep work that would not fall under most definitions of flow. So for example, being in a state of deliberate practice, where you're systematically pushing your skills past where you're comfortable so that you can improve, that's different than a flow state.
更倾向于深度工作会更令人满意的原因之一。它并不完全等同于心流。我们知道还有其他类型的状态也算作深度工作，这些状态不属于大多数心流的定义。例如，处于刻意练习的状态，你系统地将你的技能推向你舒适区之外，以便你可以提高，这与心流状态不同。
It doesn't feel pleasurable. You don't lose yourself in the time. When you're practicing like that, you feel every single second, because it's very difficult. But that also falls under the umbrella of deep work. And what about mindfulness? The idea that we should just be immersed in what we are doing, paying attention to what's going on in the moment. There are connections to mindfulness. And one of the more important connections is that we know from the study and practice of mindfulness, such as mindfulness meditation,
它感觉并不愉快。你不会在时间中迷失自己。当你那样练习时，你感觉到每一秒，因为它非常困难。但这也在深度工作的范畴之内。那么正念呢？我们应该沉浸在我们正在做的事情中，关注当下发生的事情的想法。这与正念有联系。其中一个更重要的联系是，我们从正念的研究和实践中知道，例如正念冥想，
that getting better at that type of presence is something that requires practice and training. And we see this exactly happening with deep work and a professional setting. It's something that you train and get better at, just like you can get better at certain types of meditation, that it's something you have to work at systematically.
变得更擅长那种存在感是需要练习和训练的。我们在深度工作和专业环境中看到了这一点。这是一种你训练并变得更好的东西，就像你可以通过某些类型的冥想变得更好一样，这是你必须系统地努力去做的事情。
It's a skill to be practiced, not a habit that you already know how to do and just try to make more time for. Cal Newport is the author of the book Deepwork, rules for focus success in a distracted world. When we come back, we'll talk about how you can retrain your mind to focus, to sit with a single idea for a long period of time. And we'll talk about whether creating a deeper culture for some people means that others will inevitably have to pick up the slack. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain.
这是一项需要练习的技能，而不是你已经知道如何做并只是试图腾出更多时间的习惯。卡尔·纽波特是《深度工作：在分心世界中获得卓越成就的法则》一书的作者。回来后，我们将讨论你如何重新训练你的大脑去专注，去长时间地坐下来思考一个单一的想法。我们还将讨论为某些人创造更深层的文化是否意味着其他人将不可避免地承担更多的工作。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。
Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I'm speaking to Kal Newport, a Georgetown University computer science professor, who's the author of the book Deepwork. It's about how we can cultivate the ability to focus on work, free of all distraction. Kal leads an enormously disciplined life with lots of rules and rituals. I asked him to explain how he structures his day to allow plenty of time for focused work.
请继续收听。欢迎回到《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我正在与乔治城大学计算机科学教授、《深度工作》一书的作者卡尔·纽波特交谈。它是关于我们如何培养专注于工作、不受任何干扰的能力。卡尔过着极其自律的生活，有很多规则和仪式。我请他解释他是如何安排自己的一天，以留出充足的时间进行专注工作的。
There's a few things I do. One is I've never had a social media account, and that's on purpose. It's not that I think I'm better than social media, but to the quote George Packer's essay on this, it's because I'm afraid I'll let my kids go hungry if I expose myself to that. So that's one thing I do. say on this is because I'm afraid I'd let my kids go hungry if I expose myself to that. So that's one thing I do. Two, I'm very organized with my time. I work during very set hours during the day and I plan out the day like a chess player moving the pieces around. This is when I'm going to work on win.
我做几件事。第一，我从来没有社交媒体账户，这是故意的。并不是我认为我比社交媒体更好，而是引用乔治·帕克关于此事的文章，是因为我担心如果我让自己接触到那个，我会让我的孩子挨饿。所以这是我做的一件事。说是因为我担心如果我让自己接触到那个，我会让我的孩子挨饿。所以这是我做的一件事。第二，我对我的时间非常有组织。我在白天非常固定的时间工作，我像棋手移动棋子一样规划这一天。这是我将要工作的时间。
I don't let my mood dictate how my day unfolds. And then three, I've made myself very comfortable with annoying people. I'm bad at email. I have just set the expectations that I'm just not available a lot. I'm not someone that you can expect a quick answer from. And that also causes some trouble, of course, but all this adds up to allowing me to regularly have long portions of many of my days focused on deeper thinking. I understand you actually keep a tally of how much
我不让我的情绪决定我的一天如何展开。第三，我让自己非常习惯于让人们感到恼火。我不擅长电子邮件。我只是设定了期望，即我没有太多时间。我不是那种你可以指望快速得到回答的人。当然，这也会引起一些麻烦，但所有这些加起来，让我能够定期在许多天的长时间里专注于更深入的思考。我听说你实际上记录了你做了多少
deep work you've done, how many hours you spend being uninterrupted, and you actually have targets that you must meet at the end of the day or the end of the week. Yeah, that's right. This is something until recently I was doing. I was tallying how many deep work hours, so I had to confront that. I had to confront the reality. So if I was really avoiding deep work, I would see it. I've since added a new habit to my arsenal here where I now block out my deep work on my calendar up to four weeks in advance. So I have that time protected so far out in the future that I can be sure it'll stay protected. So now I have a record
深度工作，你花了多少小时不被打断，而且你实际上有必须在一天结束或一周结束时达到的目标。是的，没错。直到最近我还在做这件事。我一直在统计深度工作的小时数，所以我必须面对它。我必须面对现实。所以如果我真的在逃避深度工作，我会看到的。我后来在我的武器库中增加了一个新习惯，我现在在我的日历上提前四周屏蔽我的深度工作。所以我把那个时间保护得非常远，以至于我可以确定它会保持受保护。所以现在我有一个记录
on my calendar of exactly what deep work I'm doing. I understand you have a fairly structured approach to shutting down at the end of the day of making sure that the tasks that remain unfinished don't bleed into your evening and your family life. I have an actual ritual I do at the end of each work day where it pretty systematically I'll look at my weekly plan, I'll look at my task licks, I'll look at my calendar, make sure that nothing is left hanging, and then I'll do a little shutdown mantra. Say an actual phrase that means I'm now done work for the day.
在我的日历上，关于我正在做的确切深度工作。我听说你在一天结束时有一个相当结构化的关闭方法，确保未完成的任务不会蔓延到你的晚上和家庭生活中。我确实有一个仪式，我在每个工作日结束时都会做，我非常系统地查看我的周计划，查看我的任务列表，查看我的日历，确保没有任何事情悬而未决，然后我会做一个小小的关闭咒语。说一个实际的短语，意味着我现在完成了这一天的工作。
What's the phrase that you tell yourself at the end of the day? I used to be embarrassed to admit. The phrase was schedule shutdown complete, but I now have this small but strong fan group that used that exact same phrase proudly. So now I'm willing to admit, it's schedule shut down complete. Do you say this without this around? No. It doesn't really matter what the phrase is.
你在一天结束时对自己说的短语是什么？我过去很不好意思承认。这个短语是“日程关闭完成”，但我现在有一个虽小但强大的粉丝群，他们自豪地使用了完全相同的短语。所以我现在愿意承认，它是“日程关闭完成”。你是在别人面前说这个吗？不。短语是什么并不重要。
I invented that phrase when I was a graduate student working on my dissertation. It was really having a hard time with coming home from the office and having all these concerns, hey, what if this proof never fixes or what if this proof breaks, what if my dissertation falls apart? And I needed something to allow me to definitively shut down. And so I was younger then, I came up with this phrase, but now it became habit, so I stuck with it. Cal, what would you say to people who say, you're asking us to turn into computers. You're asking us to behave like robots.
我在读研究生写论文时发明了这个短语。我真的很难从办公室回家，并且有所有这些担忧，嘿，如果这个证明永远修不好怎么办，或者如果这个证明坏了怎么办，如果我的论文崩溃了怎么办？我需要一些东西让我能够彻底关闭。所以我那时更年轻，我想出了这个短语，但现在它成了习惯，所以我坚持了下来。卡尔，你会对那些说“你要求我们变成电脑。你要求我们像机器人一样行事”的人说什么？
Well, see, I would argue that that's what people are doing right now. We've turned ourselves into sort of human network routers. We just sit here and process messages and sort through task lists and have this sense of busyness that treats our mind like a digital computer processor, something that you just feed instructions to and it executes one after another, I think what I'm doing is actually way more human. This idea that our brain is not like a computer,
嗯，你看，我会争辩说这就是人们现在正在做的事情。我们已经把自己变成了某种人类网络路由器。我们只是坐在这里处理消息，整理任务列表，并有一种忙碌感，把我们的大脑当作数字计算机处理器，某种你只是输入指令，它就一个接一个地执行的东西，我认为我正在做的事情实际上更人性化。这种认为我们的大脑不像电脑的想法，
it's not like any other machine we know, it's something that you have a personal connection to, and it's something that you really have to take care of, something that you have to coax high performance out of. So to have a structured day, for example, to protect your mind from distraction, I actually think makes you more human and less robotic than what most people do, which is to sit there like a human network router and just sort of process messages and tasks all day, like a blind computer processor. There seems to be a paradox here, because I think what I'm hearing you say is that scheduling yourself or even over scheduling yourself is the way to actually gain control over your life. Whereas people would sort of say if you're actually scheduling every second and sort of deciding four weeks ahead of time when you're going to stop work on a certain Wednesday,
它不像我们知道的任何其他机器，它是你与之有个人联系的东西，它是你真正必须照顾的东西，你必须从中诱导出高性能的东西。所以，例如，有一个结构化的一天，保护你的大脑免受干扰，我实际上认为这让你更人性化，而不是像大多数人那样机器人化，即像人类网络路由器一样坐在那里，整天处理消息和任务，像一个盲目的计算机处理器。这里似乎有一个悖论，因为我认为我听到你说的是，安排自己甚至过度安排自己是真正获得生活控制权的方法。而人们会说，如果你实际上安排了每一秒，并且在四周前就决定了你什么时候要在某个周三停止工作，
you've actually turned yourself into a robot. It's a paradox that shows up a lot. It confuses people, but I think you're right to point it out, is that if you study, especially really creative people, professional creatives, they are surprisingly structured in how they approach their day.
你实际上已经把自己变成了一个机器人。这是一个经常出现的悖论。它让人们感到困惑，但我认为你指出这一点是对的，即如果你研究，特别是非常有创造力的人，专业的创意人员，他们在处理一天的方式上出奇地结构化。
I took a quote at one point from David Brooks, the columnist, and I might be paraphrasing here, but basically he pointed out this observation that great creative thinkers approach their time like accountants. That this is this great disconnect is that they're very structured and systematic about their time and produce the most unstructured brilliant creative insights. So it's a key paradox to point out because I really want to emphasize it. Adding structure and control to your time really can be the key to
我曾经引用过专栏作家大卫·布鲁克斯的一句话，我在这里可能是意译，但基本上他指出了这个观察结果，即伟大的创意思想家像会计师一样对待他们的时间。这种巨大的脱节是，他们对自己的时间非常结构化和系统化，并产生了最非结构化的辉煌创意洞察。所以这是一个需要指出的关键悖论，因为我真的想强调它。为你的时间增加结构和控制确实可以是
getting the biggest insights and most interesting work produced. I'm wondering if part of the tension comes about because we actually think of inspiration as being the thing that strikes us unexpectedly. And I think the case that you're making is that inspiration actually can be scheduled to arrive on command. Well, Chuck Close said the artist, inspiration is for amateurs. I think we over focus on the inspiration piece. If you're systematically pushing yourself and your knowledge and your craft,
获得最大洞察力和产生最有趣工作的关键。我想知道这种紧张感是否部分源于我们实际上认为灵感是意外降临在我们身上的东西。我认为你提出的观点是，灵感实际上可以被安排在命令下到来。嗯，艺术家查克·克洛斯说，灵感是给业余爱好者的。我认为我们过度关注灵感部分。如果你系统地推动自己、你的知识和你的工艺，
you will have inspiration. It'll happen in the shower, it'll happen while you walk to work. What's important is setting yourself up to have that inspiration and then giving yourself the time and structure you need to act on it to actually produce something of value out of it. So I downplay the importance of inspiration and I emphasize the importance of creating a life or inspiration as possible and you're well suited to act on it.
你就会有灵感。它会发生在淋浴时，它会发生在你步行上班时。重要的是让自己准备好拥有这种灵感，然后给自己时间和你需要的结构来采取行动，真正从中产生有价值的东西。所以我淡化了灵感的重要性，我强调了创造一种生活或灵感是可能的，并且你很适合采取行动的重要性。
I want to ask you a couple of questions that push back against this idea from a practical standpoint. What if people are in workplaces where they have managers and bosses who aren't enlightened enough to say yes, you should spend several hours engaged in deep work? People can't always choose for themselves what kind of work they pursue. Something that has seemed to be effective is in that type of situation, having a conversation with whoever your boss is, whoever supervises you. And so I want to talk about deep work. Here's what deep work is.
我想问你几个从实际角度反驳这个想法的问题。如果人们在工作场所，他们的经理和老板不够开明，不能说“是的，你应该花几个小时进行深度工作”怎么办？人们并不总是能为自己选择追求什么样的工作。在那种情况下，似乎有效的一件事是与你的老板，或者监督你的人进行对话。所以我想谈谈深度工作。这就是深度工作。
I want to talk about non-deep worker shallow work. And here's what that is. And both are important to my job. And I want to have a conversation and decide what should my ratio be. That is a typical work week. What ratio of my hours should be deep work versus shallow work and actually nailing down a number and aspirational target that everyone agrees, yeah, this is right
我想谈谈非深度工作或浅层工作。这就是它。两者对我的工作都很重要。我想进行一次对话，决定我的比例应该是多少。这是一个典型的工作周。我的工作时间中，深度工作与浅层工作的比例应该是多少，并真正确定一个每个人都同意的数字和愿望目标，是的，这对于
for your position in our company. It's not saying, hey, boss, stop emailing me so much you annoy me. Since then, saying, hey, let's try to optimize myself. So what should I be going for here? Let me get your feedback on this. And people are reporting back to me, you know, tales of drastic changes to work cultures that they thought there's no way. There's no way I'm going to get away with this.
你在我们公司的职位是正确的。这不是说，嘿，老板，别再给我发那么多电子邮件了，你让我很烦。而是说，嘿，让我们尝试优化我。所以我在这里应该追求什么？让我听听你对此的反馈。人们正在向我报告，你知道，他们认为不可能的工作文化发生了巨大变化。我不可能逃脱这个。
I'm supposed to be on slack all the time or I'm supposed to be answering my emails all the time. They have this conversation in the next week. They're spending 50% of their hours on distracted. So I've been pushing that particular managerial hack as a good, positive way forward to trying to fix some of these issues. I'm wondering if some people might say your advice is really advice for people who in some ways are at the top of their food chains.
我应该一直在线，或者我应该一直回复我的电子邮件。他们在下周进行了这次对话。他们 50% 的时间都在分心。所以我一直在推动那个特定的管理黑客，作为解决其中一些问题的一种好的、积极的前进方式。我想知道是否有些人会说你的建议确实是给那些在某种程度上处于食物链顶端的人的建议。
So if you have an author who basically is able to say I'm going to disconnect from the world for 18 months, I'm just going to focus on writing this book. You know, someone else is probably picking up after this person in all kinds of different ways. If Cal Newport says, you know, I'm going to close the door in my office. I'm not going to answer my phone. I'm not going to check my email. But someone needs to get in touch with you in an emergency. That person is probably going to reach an assistant of yours. And that assistant doesn't have the same luxury of deep work as you do because he or she needs to be available to to hear what the emergency is or to hear what the request
所以如果你有一位作者，他基本上能够说我要与世界断开 18 个月，我只是要专注于写这本书。你知道，其他人可能以各种不同的方式在处理这个人的后续工作。如果卡尔·纽波特说，你知道，我要关上办公室的门。我不接电话。我不检查电子邮件。但有人需要在紧急情况下与你联系。那个人可能会联系你的助手。而那个助手没有像你那样的深度工作奢侈，因为他或她需要随时待命，以听到紧急情况是什么，或者听到请求
is. Does having a group of people who are engaged in deep work necessarily mean they must be essentially a second tier of workers who are engaged in shallow work to allow the deep thinkers to do that deep thinking? It doesn't require that, but it usually requires some type of reconfiguration of communication channels and expectations. So when I work for example with people maybe in a small consultancy that is client-facing, where they're used to this idea that clients need to reach us issues pop up, what's important there to enable more deep work, which in the end produces more value for everyone,
是什么。拥有一群从事深度工作的人是否必然意味着他们必须基本上是从事浅层工作的二线工人，以允许深度思想家进行那种深度思考？它不需要那样，但它通常需要某种沟通渠道和期望的重组。所以当我与人合作时，例如在一家面向客户的小型咨询公司，他们习惯于客户需要联系我们，问题会出现的想法，在那里实现更多深度工作，最终为每个人产生更多价值，重要的是
is just to actually change the communication expectations that maybe instead of having a client just have individual people's email addresses, the company sets up an email address for that client. And the company has set up some agreement on there in that there'll always be someone monitoring that, and here's the expectation of when you can get a response. Or maybe setting up a, sometimes called the bat phone,
实际上改变沟通期望，也许不是让客户只拥有个人的电子邮件地址，公司为该客户设置一个电子邮件地址。公司已经达成了一些协议，即总会有人监控它，这是你可以得到回复的期望。或者也许设置一个，有时被称为“蝙蝠电话”，
or emergency phone idea, where you say, okay, here's a number you can call me at. If there's an emergency when I'm in one of these deep work sessions, people set these up and say they get called maybe once a year. So I don't think you need actual extra people involved to make space for deep work. But I do think it almost always requires some effort, some sort of reconfiguration of people's expectations
或紧急电话的想法，你说，好吧，这是你可以打给我的号码。如果我在这些深度工作会议之一时有紧急情况，人们设置这些并说他们可能一年被叫一次。所以我不认为你需要额外的人员参与来为深度工作腾出空间。但我确实认为它几乎总是需要一些努力，某种对人们期望的重组
on how and when they can reach you. So I'm going to ask your question now that's part serious and part teasing. You and I was scheduled to talk last week and you didn't get the appointment down in your calendar and I was sitting here waiting for you. And of course, this kind of thing happens all the time, but in your case, I couldn't help but wonder,
关于他们如何以及何时可以联系你。所以我现在要问你一个既严肃又带点调侃的问题。你和我原定上周谈话，你没有把预约记在你的日历上，我坐在这里等你。当然，这种事情经常发生，但在你的情况下，我不禁想知道，
did he miss this because he actually hadn't spent the time doing the shallow work to get this in his calendar? And is it possible that when we engage in deep work, we are essentially getting the benefit of all of that deep work, we're getting the deep thinking, we're getting the accomplishments, but some of the cost is born by other people, and they might actually be the people who are getting mad at you when they can't reach you. Well, it's a good point, and I think that's actually what happened, because I spend
他错过这个是因为他实际上没有花时间做浅层工作把它记在日历上吗？是否可能当我们从事深度工作时，我们基本上获得了所有那些深度工作的好处，我们得到了深度思考，我们得到了成就，但部分代价是由其他人承担的，而他们可能实际上是那些当你无法联系到他们时会对你生气的人。嗯，这是一个很好的观点，我认为这实际上就是发生的事情，因为我花
a lot of time working away for my computer, these type of problems happened to me more often. In this case, I'm embarrassed it happened, but my vague memory was I saw this communication on my phone because I had to be on there to send something to someone, but I was far away from a computer. And so I wasn't able to easily add it to a calendar. And I was like, okay, I'll remember to do this when I get back to my office next and I forgot. And it did cause problems.
了很多时间在远离电脑的地方工作，这类问题发生在我身上更频繁。在这种情况下，我很尴尬它发生了，但我模糊的记忆是我在手机上看到了这个沟通，因为我必须在上面给某人发送东西，但我离电脑很远。所以我无法轻易地把它加到日历上。我想，好吧，我回到办公室后会记得做这件事，但我忘了。它确实造成了问题。
And so I'm embarrassed about it. And that type of thing does happen. And I think this hits on a big point, which is deep work, or a professional life focused on deep work, is less convenient for most people involved. But on the other hand, I want to put out there this notion that that might not be so bad. It's possible that in this age of digital communication, we are focusing too much on convenience over effectiveness. I think in some ways what you're saying is also the tension between the short term and
所以我对此感到尴尬。这类事情确实会发生。我认为这触及了一个大问题，即深度工作，或专注于深度工作的职业生活，对大多数相关人员来说不太方便。但另一方面，我想提出这个概念，即这可能并不那么糟糕。可能在这个数字通信时代，我们过于关注便利性而忽视了有效性。我认为在某种程度上你所说的是短期和
the long term. If I don't respond to a colleague's request or a manager's instructions to do something right away, It's irritating for the person at the other end of the line. And so I think most of us actually conformed to the social norm of saying, yes, I'm just going to be responsive, I'm going to be available, I'm going to answer the question as soon as it's asked. The point that you're making though is that they might be long-term goals, deeper institutional goals, that are essentially we're not thinking about. And of of course when those goals are not met because they're not articulated no one notices their absence. So people will
长期之间的紧张关系。如果我不立即回复同事的请求或经理的指示去做某事，对电话另一端的人来说是令人恼火的。所以我认为我们大多数人实际上顺应了“是的，我会做出回应，我会随时待命，我会一被问到就回答问题”的社会规范。然而，你提出的观点是，可能存在长期目标，更深层的机构目标，我们基本上没有考虑到。当然，当这些目标因为没有被表达出来而没有实现时，没有人会注意到它们的缺失。所以人们会
notice it if you don't show up at an interview, people are not going to notice it if you don't write that bestseller or the next great idea. And so there's really a cultural bias in favor of the trivial over protecting what actually is most important. I really agree with that point and I would add to it that I think a big part of it is lack of metrics. So if we look at two parallel case studies, two different industries. Let's look at the industrial revolution and the rise of mass industrial production. This was a world where the metrics for productivity were very clear. How many cars per hour is our factory producing? And what we saw in that world
注意到如果你没有参加面试，人们不会注意到如果你没有写出那本畅销书或下一个伟大的想法。所以确实存在一种文化偏见，即偏向于琐碎的事情，而不是保护真正最重要的事情。我非常同意这一点，我想补充一点，我认为很大一部分原因是缺乏指标。所以如果我们看两个平行的案例研究，两个不同的行业。让我们看看工业革命和大规模工业生产的兴起。这是一个生产力指标非常明确的世界。我们的工厂每小时生产多少辆汽车？我们在那个世界中看到的是
where bottom line value was very easy to measure is that very quickly the structure of work moved away from what was convenient for the workers and towards what produced more value. It moved away from the old system and factories where you had people working teams at one spot in the floor to assemble the car towards things like the assembly line, which are incredibly inconvenient. It's very hard to manage the assembly line. It's very hard to get it right.
底线价值非常容易衡量的地方在于，工作结构很快就从方便员工转向了创造更多价值。它脱离了旧的体系和工厂，即人们在车间的一个点上以团队形式组装汽车，转向了像装配线这样的东西，这非常不方便。管理装配线非常困难。要做好它非常困难。
It causes lots of issues. It's annoying, but it produces a lot more value. You move to digital knowledge work. We don't have those metrics. It's much harder to measure, okay, what's the cost to our bottom line if you're more distracted or less distracted? And so my conjecture is that without those metrics, we are going to fall back on these interpersonal or cultural biases. We're wired to be social. We don't want to upset someone. These type of biases
它会导致很多问题。这很烦人，但它能产生更多的价值。你转向了数字知识工作。我们没有这些指标。要衡量如果你更分心或更不分心对我们底线的影响，要困难得多，对吧？所以我的推测是，如果没有这些指标，我们将退回到这些个人或文化偏见中。我们天生就是社交动物。我们不想让别人生气。这类偏见
take over because it's much harder to measure in this new world, the impact of different behaviors. I'm wondering if there's also a psychological explanation for the phenomenon you're describing, and what I mean by it is this. I took a vacation a couple of weeks ago, and for the first time in a long time, I actually decided to unplug. So I didn't have internet access. I wasn't checking my email, I literally was cut off from things going on at work. And when I got back, there were a number of things that had happened in my absence, some of which I wish I'd had the chance to weigh in on. But when I looked at the aggregate, the overall conclusion I got was really that the world
占据了主导地位，因为在这个新世界里，衡量不同行为的影响要困难得多。我想知道你所描述的现象是否也有心理学解释，我的意思是这样的。几周前我休假了，这是很久以来第一次，我真的决定断开连接。所以我没有互联网接入。我没有查看电子邮件，我真的与工作中发生的事情隔绝了。当我回来时，在我缺席期间发生了一些事情，其中一些我希望有机会发表意见。但当我从总体上看时，我得出的总体结论确实是世界
did just fine in my absence. Things went fine. I actually wasn't as indispensable as I thought I was. I'm wondering if that might be a psychological driver in people being unwilling to actually cut themselves off, because not only might they discover that they are more productive, but they might also discover the world is just fine. Thank you very much without you. Yeah, I think that's one of three big psychological drivers
在我缺席的情况下做得很好。事情进展顺利。我其实并没有我想象中那么不可或缺。我想知道这是否可能是人们不愿意真正切断联系的心理驱动因素，因为他们不仅可能会发现自己效率更高，而且还可能会发现世界其实很好。非常感谢，没有你。是的，我认为这是三大心理驱动因素之一
that have led us to this world where and now of the sort of constant connectivity business. So that's certainly one, I think that's one of three big psychological drivers that have led us to this world we're now of the sort of constant connectivity business. So that's certainly one, I think, this notion of we get a sense of meeting and usefulness out of constantly being involved in interaction. I think the other two psychological drivers, one is just where we're wired to be tribal and it's very difficult for us psychologically to know logically, to know there's an email waiting that we're not answering. And even if we know for a fact that the person
导致我们进入这个世界，现在是那种持续连接的业务。所以这当然是一个，我认为这是导致我们进入这个世界的三个大心理驱动因素之一，现在是那种持续连接的业务。所以这当然是一个，我认为，这种我们从不断的互动中获得意义感和有用感的概念。我认为另外两个心理驱动因素，一个是我们就天生是部落化的，在心理上很难知道逻辑上，知道有一封电子邮件在等着我们，而我们没有回复。即使我们确实知道那个人
who sent that message does not need a fast response, it still feels like we're at the tribal fire. And there's a tribe member standing there tapping you on the shoulder and you're ignoring them. We just have a very hard time with that. And I think the third driver is, knowledge work is much less structured. And so how do you prove to your organization or to your boss that you're valuable? And
发送该消息的人不需要快速回复，但感觉就像我们在部落火堆旁。有一个部落成员站在那里拍你的肩膀，而你却在无视他们。我们对此感到非常困难。我认为第三个驱动因素是，知识工作的结构性要差得多。那么你如何向你的组织或老板证明你是有价值的呢？而且
busyness as a proxy for productivity is something that a lot of people have defaulted to. Well, at the very least, if you see, I'm sending lots of messages you know I'm working. And so I think those three different factors are all intertwining to get us to this place, where we find ourselves just constantly sending messages as opposed to thinking hard thoughts or producing new things. Cal Newport is a computer science professor at Georgetown University. He's the author of Deep Work, Rules for Focus Success in a Distracted World. Cal, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Well, thank you. After the break, we'll go to a psychology lab that's trying to help people
忙碌作为生产力的代理是很多人默认的事情。好吧，至少，如果你看到，我发送了很多消息，你知道我在工作。所以我认为这三个不同的因素交织在一起，把我们带到了这个地方，我们发现自己只是不断地发送消息，而不是进行深入思考或生产新事物。卡尔·纽波特是乔治城大学的计算机科学教授。他是《深度工作：在分心世界中获得成功的规则》一书的作者。卡尔，感谢你今天加入我的“隐藏大脑”节目。好吧，谢谢。休息之后，我们将去一个心理学实验室，试图帮助人们
bounce back from interruptions more easily. All it takes is a little electricity. You should start to feel something pretty soon if you're already. I'm feeling a very very mild tingling. That's coming up in just a moment. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Earlier in the show, I talked to the computer science professor Kall Newport about how important and rare it is these days to carve out time for uninterrupted work. He shared some ideas about how to develop deep attention. These ideas, no surprise, require real commitment and resolve.
更容易地从中断中恢复过来。只需要一点电。如果你已经准备好了，你应该很快就会感觉到什么。我感觉到一种非常非常轻微的刺痛感。这马上就会到来。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听“隐藏大脑”。这是“隐藏大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在节目早些时候，我与计算机科学教授卡尔·纽波特谈到了如今为不间断工作留出时间是多么重要和罕见。他分享了一些关于如何培养深度注意力的想法。这些想法，不出所料，需要真正的承诺和决心。
So I decided to explore a shortcut. A few months ago, I was driving to Virginia for an interview and I was doing the opposite of decoy. I was watching the road paying attention to GPS directions, and I was listening to an interview I'd conducted years ago with a researcher, Eric Blumberg. I was on my way to an interview with one of Eric's colleagues, and I needed to re-familiarize myself with the material. So the irony here, of course, is that I'm heading to an interview about interruptions while being constantly interrupted.
所以我决定探索一条捷径。几个月前，我开车去弗吉尼亚州参加面试，我做的正好与诱饵相反。我盯着路，注意GPS导航，我正在听我几年前采访一位研究员埃里克·布隆伯格的录音。我正在去采访埃里克的一位同事的路上，我需要重新熟悉这些材料。所以这里的讽刺之处当然是，我正要去参加一个关于中断的采访，同时却不断地被中断。
The interview I was going to was about how to deal with interruptions and distractions. Now there's no question, I'd love to do my deep thinking and the kinds of places Cal Newport described, places like Carl Jung's Lakeside House and the Swiss Countryside, or J.K. Rowling's Suite in Edinburgh. But I need something a little more... I was gonna say cheap, but why don't we say practical? That's where Eric and his colleague Melissa Schildrup come in. They're exploring a relatively simple solution to the problem of interruptions and overwork. Basically, you run a small electrical current through part of the brain and voila, it's easier to manage interruptions. It's now year since this interview with Eric, a new researcher has taken over the project and I'm heading to the lab along with my producer
我要去的那个采访是关于如何处理中断和分心的。现在毫无疑问，我很乐意在卡尔·纽波特描述的那种地方进行深度思考，比如卡尔·荣格的湖畔小屋和瑞士乡村，或者J.K.罗琳在爱丁堡的套房。但我需要一些更……我本来想说便宜，但我们为什么不说实用呢？这就是埃里克和他的同事梅丽莎·希尔德鲁普发挥作用的地方。他们正在探索一个解决中断和过度工作问题的相对简单的方案。基本上，你让一股微小的电流通过大脑的一部分，瞧，处理中断就更容易了。距离这次采访埃里克已经过去一年了，一位新的研究员接手了这个项目，我正和我的制片人一起前往实验室
Raina Cohen. I've offered myself over as a guinea pig for the experiment, and I'm a little worried. The squeals of pain coming from the host is what makes this worthwhile. Rainer doesn't show much sympathy. Putting your money where your math is, you've been reaping the rewards of the many undergraduate students who have subjected themselves to social science research and now you have to be part of it. Fair as fair. As fair as it might be, the idea of running an electrical current through my head is not
蕾娜·科恩。我已经自愿作为实验的实验品，我有点担心。主持人发出的痛苦尖叫声是让这一切变得值得的原因。蕾娜并没有表现出太多的同情。把你的钱花在你的数学上，你一直在享受许多本科生作为社会科学研究对象的成果，现在你必须成为其中的一部分。公平就是公平。尽管这很公平，但让电流通过我的头部的想法并不
exactly appealing. But the possibility that I could juggle the many demands on my time, that's irresistible. Something hugely seductive about this idea that you can wear a helmet and instead of being able to do one thing at a time, you can now do four things at a time. Wait, which way am I going now? I decided to turn off the interview with Eric and focus on the road. Once I make it at the campus of George Mason, I find my way to Melissa's lab. It turns out to be less sci-fi than grunge.
完全吸引人。但如果我能处理好时间上的许多需求，那将是不可抗拒的。这个想法非常有诱惑力，你可以戴上头盔，而不是一次只能做一件事，现在你可以一次做四件事。等等，我现在往哪边走？我决定关掉埃里克的采访，专注于道路。一旦我到达乔治梅森大学的校园，我就找到了去梅丽莎实验室的路。结果发现它不像科幻小说，更像是垃圾摇滚。
They keep us graduating from the basement, so I can't go through the door window. This is Melissa's shelter, Eric's colleague and my guide for the experiment. Melissa's work at the Human Factors in Applied Cognition Research Lab is inspired by a single insight. There's a reason some people bounce back from interruptions quickly and other people don't. One thought with interruptions is that they are highly dependent on a person's working memory capacity, so your natural ability to manipulate information in your brain. People who are generally good at that have less of a negative effect of interruptions and people who are not so good at it seem to be affected more.
他们让我们从地下室毕业，所以我不能穿过门窗。这是梅丽莎·希尔德鲁普，埃里克的同事，也是我这次实验的向导。梅丽莎在应用认知研究实验室的人为因素方面的工作受到一个洞察的启发。有些人能迅速从中断中恢复过来，而另一些人则不能，这是有原因的。关于中断的一个想法是，它们高度依赖于一个人的工作记忆容量，也就是你大脑中处理信息的天生能力。通常擅长这一点的人受中断的负面影响较小，而不太擅长的人似乎受到的影响更大。
Melissa and her colleagues want to know if there's a way to improve working memory. In other words, can you help people hold more information in their heads? If you can do this, interruptions might not be such a big problem. That brings us to the brain's app. If you want to influence how people deal with interruptions, it makes sense to try and stimulate a part of the brain that handles working memory, the prefrontal cortex. Very simplistically, it's like a nine volt battery that we have electrodes attached to,
梅丽莎和她的同事们想知道是否有一种方法可以改善工作记忆。换句话说，你能帮助人们在脑海中容纳更多信息吗？如果你能做到这一点，中断可能就不会成为一个大问题。这就把我们带到了大脑的应用程序。如果你想影响人们处理中断的方式，尝试刺激大脑中处理工作记忆的部分——前额叶皮层是有意义的。非常简单地说，它就像一个我们连接了电极的九伏电池，
and depending on where you put the electrodes on the brain, you can either make it more difficult for neurons to fire or make it more easy for them to fire. Scientists have long inserted electrodes into the brain to change the way the brain works. Doing this helps patients with serious disorders like Parkinson's disease. I've signed up for a much less invasive procedure
根据你把电极放在大脑的什么位置，你可以让神经元更难放电，或者让它们更容易放电。科学家们长期以来一直将电极插入大脑以改变大脑的工作方式。这样做有助于帕金森病等严重疾病的患者。我已经报名参加了一个侵入性小得多的程序
and electrode attached to the side of my head. Now obviously running a small current through the brain is a crude way to change how it works. So this really is a little bit like just slapping the side of the television set, isn't it? There's a lot of that. Yep, there's a lot of wiggle room and out works. I'm often juggling multiple things at the same time.
一个连接在我头侧的电极。显然，让一股微小的电流通过大脑是一种改变其工作方式的粗糙方法。所以这真的有点像拍打电视机的一侧，不是吗？有很多这种情况。是的，有很多回旋余地，而且有效。我经常同时处理多件事。
So what would be your hypothesis on what the effect is of this helmet on my behavior and performance? I would. If we're going to extend it out there to your entire life, it should in theory help you juggle all the multitask you have going on. If you need a working memory boost, then it will allow you to focus on one thing, stop focusing on that, move to something else, and then go back and pick up where you were without much of a degradation of performance, ideally, that's the goal.
那么你对这个头盔对我的行为和表现的影响有什么假设？我会的。如果我们把它扩展到你的整个生活，理论上它应该能帮助你处理你所进行的所有多任务。如果你需要工作记忆的提升，那么它将允许你专注于一件事，停止专注于那件事，转向别的事情，然后回去并在你离开的地方继续，而不会有太大的性能下降，理想情况下，这就是目标。
And what is the potential downside? Well, if you were to invest in a system like this, there's no guarantee it's going to work. There's really no negative effects that have been associated with it. There's always a possibility that we're heading the wrong area in the brain. We don't do brain scans before we do this on people because it is pretty diffuse. So we could be accidentally, while enhancing your working memory, we could also be hurting your verbal skills. Oh, great.
潜在的缺点是什么？好吧，如果你要投资这样一个系统，不能保证它会起作用。真的没有与之相关的负面影响。总有可能我们击中了大脑中错误的区域。我们在对人进行此操作之前不会进行脑部扫描，因为它非常弥散。所以我们可能会意外地，在增强你的工作记忆的同时，我们也可能在损害你的语言技能。哦，太棒了。
So yes, but it's all trans-story, it's going to stop once the stimulation stops, which are really thereafter. So it's not permanent. The electrical stimulation won't affect me permanently, but what about helping me deal with interruptions in the short term? To find out, Melissa has me play a computer game. So you're going to be playing a game called Warship Commander? It looks a lot like battleship.
所以是的，但这都是暂时的，一旦刺激停止它就会停止，这才是我们真正追求的。所以它不是永久性的。电刺激不会永久影响我，但帮助我短期内处理中断呢？为了找出答案，梅丽莎让我玩一个电脑游戏。所以你要玩一个叫“战舰指挥官”的游戏？它看起来很像战舰。
It has a 1990s video game feel to it. It's a very dark blue background, and my ship is at the bottom of the screen, and planes of different kinds are coming in from the top. I have to shoot down enemy planes and let friendly ones get through. There are lots and lots of rules. If it is an enemy, you warn it, here at the warn button, wait five seconds and then fire on it. Red planes are enemies, blue planes are friends,
它有一种1990年代电子游戏的感觉。背景是深蓝色的，我的船在屏幕底部，不同种类的飞机从顶部飞来。我必须击落敌机，让友军飞机通过。有很多很多的规则。如果是敌人，你警告它，按这里的警告按钮，等五秒钟，然后向它开火。红色的飞机是敌人，蓝色的飞机是朋友，
but then there are yellow planes, which could be either friend or fo. If it's yellow, what you'll need to do is click on it, find the highlighted number here on the side, click on that, and then it will tell you here in the communications window if it's a friend or a foe. Okay, click this button to shoot down foes, make sure you don't shoot friends, and a complicated system to figure out who is who. I'm ready to go, but those are all just the rules of the main task. While you're doing that, you're going to be
但还有黄色的飞机，可能是朋友也可能是敌人。如果是黄色的，你需要做的是点击它，找到侧面这里高亮显示的数字，点击它，然后它会在通信窗口告诉你它是朋友还是敌人。好的，点击这个按钮击落敌人，确保不要射击朋友，这是一个弄清楚谁是谁的复杂系统。我准备好了，但这些都只是主要任务的规则。当你做这些的时候，你将会
hearing some information from the rest of your main task. While you're doing that, you're going to be hearing some information from the rest of your staff on the worship. And it's going to be things like your current water level is 355, our current communications channel is Oscar. And they're going to be giving you several updates while you're playing. By these updates relevant to the game, or can I just ignore them?
听到来自你主要任务其余部分的一些信息。当你做这些的时候，你将会听到来自你战舰上其余工作人员的一些信息。它会是像你当前的水位是355，我们当前的通信频道是奥斯卡。他们会在你玩的时候给你几个更新。这些更新与游戏相关吗，还是我可以忽略它们？
So then somebody's going to come on and ask you, all right, what's the current? Oh, communications. So that's the interrupting task. So then you need to answer the question, and then you can go back to what you're doing. So there are lots of rules and lots of moving parts. Naturally, I do the mature thing
所以然后有人会进来问你，好吧，当前的是什么？哦，通信。所以这就是中断任务。所以你需要回答这个问题，然后你可以回到你正在做的事情。所以有很多规则和很多移动部件。自然地，我做了成熟的事情
and make up excuses even before the game starts. Can I just say that your volunteers don't have to play the game with a microphone one inch in front of their mouths? If you would like to have that as a caveat and a handicap, then yeah, you can put that on there. I play a practice run. Alright, well I'm still getting used to all the elements of the game. Was I listening to what? The current course.
甚至在游戏开始之前就编造借口。我可以只说你的志愿者不必在嘴前一英寸处拿着麦克风玩游戏吗？如果你想把它作为一个警告和障碍，那么是的，你可以把它加上。我玩了一次练习。好吧，我还在适应游戏的所有元素。我刚才在听什么？当前的航向。
Uh, no, I have no idea what the current course is. You can take a machine and start and then it go the way so you'll get the next one. Now that I know the rules, I start a new game. This time, the results count. They're going to give me a baseline score that Melissa can later compare to how I do with the electrodes on. I destroy some enemy planes. I get a few things right.
呃，不，我不知道当前的航向是什么。你可以拿一台机器开始，然后它走那条路，所以你会得到下一个。现在我知道规则了，我开始了一个新游戏。这一次，结果很重要。他们会给我一个基准分数，梅丽莎以后可以将其与我戴上电极后的表现进行比较。我摧毁了一些敌机。我做对了一些事情。
Yes. And I make some mistakes. What is our current course? I think it's 0, 3, 0. I think. Oh no, I guess not. Once the game is over, Melissa gives me a performance evaluation.
是的。我犯了一些错误。我们当前的航向是什么？我想是0, 3, 0。我想。哦不，我想不是。游戏结束后，梅丽莎给了我一个表现评估。
She thinks I did. Okay. You were very focused on the primary task and not so much the interruption task. So what do we know next? And how do you improve my performance? Alright so now we put on the helmet. Melissa put some things on the table.
她认为我做得还可以。你非常专注于主要任务，而不是中断任务。那么我们接下来知道什么？你如何提高我的表现？好吧，现在我们戴上头盔。梅丽莎在桌子上放了一些东西。
A little black box with knobs which is known as a trans-cranial direct currents simulation unit. Some cords, electrodes which look like squares that have rubber on the edges and thin sponges in the middle. Melissa prepares my head and arm before she attaches the electrodes. Don't be nervous. I'm not nervous.
一个小黑盒子，上面有旋钮，被称为经颅直流电刺激装置。一些电线，看起来像边缘有橡胶、中间有薄海绵的正方形电极。梅丽莎在连接电极之前准备了我的头部和手臂。不要紧张。我不紧张。
It's all great. All great. I will live. I'm an expert. Yes. Sort of. She wipes a spot on my forehead, then on my upper arm. She picks up a syringe to add saline to the electrodes. Before I came to the lab, I thought I was going to be wearing a helmet for this experiment,
一切都很好。一切都很好。我会活下来的。我是专家。是的。算是吧。她擦了擦我额头上的一个点，然后是我的上臂。她拿起注射器给电极添加盐水。在我来到实验室之前，我以为我会戴着头盔进行这个实验，
so I asked Melissa why she isn't giving me one. It turns out the helmet is still in the idea stage, a standard helmet won't work because everyone has a different head size. What I get instead are white bandages wrapped around my head and arm. There's no mirror, so the only two people in the room with me, Melissa and my producer, they tell me how I look. You kind of look like a World War I patient that got hit in the head and has a white band around your forehead.
所以我问梅丽莎为什么不给我一个。事实证明，头盔还处于构思阶段，标准的头盔行不通，因为每个人的头型大小都不一样。我得到的是缠在头和手臂上的白色绷带。没有镜子，所以房间里和我在一起的两个人，梅丽莎和我的制片人，他们告诉我我看起来怎么样。你看起来有点像一战中头部受伤、前额缠着白色绷带的病人。
This is really like Richard Simmons sweat band plus like the cable that you put in the back of the TV to set up the audio, like a little red plug. Yeah. Yes, yeah. It looks a lot like that. Then there's my arm. The electrode feels like a medical device.
这真的很像理查德·西蒙斯的汗带，加上你放在电视机后面设置音频的电缆，就像一个小红插头。是的。是的，是的。看起来很像那样。然后是我的手臂。电极感觉像医疗设备。
Which looks kind of like a blood pressure cuff? Melissa asks me if I'm ready, and I say yes. You should start to feel something pretty soon, if you don't already. I'm feeling a very, very mild tingling. It feels like how to describe it, but just like a slightly burning sensation, but it's fairly mild and it's fairly focused and intense. And it's right over my right temple. With electricity running through my skull, I start the game again. Alright, new and improved chunker with superpowers of concentration.
看起来有点像血压计袖带？梅丽莎问我准备好了吗，我说准备好了。如果你还没感觉到，你应该很快就会感觉到什么。我感觉到一种非常非常轻微的刺痛感。感觉就像，怎么描述它，但就像一种轻微的灼烧感，但它相当温和，而且相当集中和强烈。它就在我右太阳穴上方。电流通过我的头骨，我再次开始游戏。好吧，新的、改进的尚卡尔，拥有专注的超能力。
I'm going to start the experiment now. This time, I get four out of six questions right on the interruption task. I improved, but that could be just a fluke. I play another game. You got them all right. All right. Melissa explains exactly what all the plane destroying and messages about freshwater levels actually reveal about my working memory. I have to remember the game's complicated
我现在要开始实验了。这一次，我在中断任务上答对了六个问题中的四个。我进步了，但这可能只是侥幸。我玩了另一场游戏。你全答对了。好的。梅丽莎准确地解释了所有的飞机摧毁和关于淡水水位的消息实际上揭示了我的工作记忆的什么。我必须记住游戏复杂的
rules. That takes up some of my working memory. I have to keep track of the constant verbal updates. Communication channel is now out of focus. some of my working memory. I have to keep track of the constant verbal updates. These interruptions mean I have to store all this information in my head even as I'm trying to keep enemy planes from blowing me up. The key thing that Melissa is measuring about the interruptions is... What happens after you respond to that task? Are you able to go back right away and pick up where you were? How would you say I performed?
规则。这占用了我的一些工作记忆。我必须跟踪不断的口头更新。通信频道现在失焦了。我的一些工作记忆。我必须跟踪不断的口头更新。这些中断意味着我必须把所有这些信息存储在脑海中，即使我正试图阻止敌机炸毁我。梅丽莎衡量中断的关键点是……你在响应那个任务后会发生什么？你能马上回去并在你离开的地方继续吗？你觉得我表现如何？
You performed pretty well for being your second game or third game. You did pretty well, especially with the interrupting task. I was very impressed. Normally, we have to remind people that they need to focus on that and try it. Do you think that the electrodes made a difference? As a scientist, I cannot say that with an end of one in two games.
对于你的第二场或第三场游戏来说，你表现得相当不错。你做得很好，特别是在中断任务方面。我印象非常深刻。通常，我们必须提醒人们他们需要专注于此并尝试。你认为电极有影响吗？作为一名科学家，我不能说在两场游戏中只有一个样本的情况下是这样。
It's very rare you see something that's like, you can identify visually that somebody is better from intervention right away like this. So it's over time looking at data. So I could go looking at your data and look at during the practice games, what happened after you answered those questions, how long did it take you to make your next step? Did you make the correct next step? Did you go back? Did you skip things? And then
你很少看到像这样可以直观地识别出某人通过干预立即变得更好的东西。所以这是随着时间的推移查看数据。所以我可以去查看你的数据，看看在练习游戏期间，你在回答那些问题后发生了什么，你花了多长时间进行下一步？你做了正确的下一步吗？你回去了吗？你跳过了什么吗？然后
compare them numerically to how you did with the electrodes on. I asked Melissa if I should strap electrodes to my head when I'm dealing with interruptions at work. You could do that. This probably isn't the best real world technique, but there are, it informs other techniques. So if we know that modulating working memory performance or working memory ability affects these things, then we can say what techniques can maybe supplement your working memory. When Melissa and her colleagues analyze the results, they take all kinds of factors into account. For example, it may be that people are better at multitasking
在数值上与你戴上电极后的表现进行比较。我问梅丽莎，当我在工作中处理中断时，我是否应该把电极绑在头上。你可以那样做。这可能不是最好的现实世界技术，但有，它为其他技术提供了信息。所以如果我们知道调节工作记忆表现或工作记忆能力会影响这些事情，那么我们可以说哪些技术可以补充你的工作记忆。当梅丽莎和她的同事分析结果时，他们考虑了各种因素。例如，人们可能更擅长多任务处理
after some time, just because they've had more practice with the game. It might be that when they wear the electrodes, there's a placebo effect going on, they think they're going to do better, and so they actually do better. But when Melissa and her colleagues take all of this and other factors into account, the electrodes still seem to make a difference. So I have a question that's not really a science question, it might be more of a philosophical question. I remember when we started using smartphones, and they seemed like enormous time saving devices. They allowed you to do in five minutes what used to take you two hours.
过了一段时间，只是因为他们对游戏有了更多的练习。可能是当他们戴上电极时，有一种安慰剂效应，他们认为自己会做得更好，所以他们实际上做得更好。但当梅丽莎和她的同事将所有这些和其他因素考虑在内时，电极似乎仍然产生了影响。所以我有一个问题，这不是一个科学问题，可能更像是一个哲学问题。我记得当我们开始使用智能手机时，它们看起来像是巨大的节省时间的设备。它们让你在五分钟内完成过去需要两个小时才能完成的事情。
And initially, the argument was, you now are gonna have an hour and 55 minutes to take a walk in the park and smell the roses. But of course, that isn't what happened. We just filled the hour and 55 minutes with other stuff to do. And now you're just as busy, probably even more busy than you were before, except you're doing 20 tasks instead of one. And I'm wondering, as we come up with these techniques that might actually improve
起初，争论是，你现在将有一个小时55分钟去公园散步，闻闻玫瑰花香。但当然，事情并没有那样发生。我们只是用其他事情填满了那一个小时55分钟。现在你和以前一样忙，可能比以前更忙，只是你在做20项任务而不是一项。我想知道，当我们提出这些可能真正改善
the efficiency with which our brains work, isn't it possible that we'll just simply use the balance of time to do even more stuff? I think that's exactly correct. There's a debate going on in this field and in cybernics in general. Should we really be doing these things? Is it really helpful to humanity or the person? My feeling is that we've always made technological advances and they've always been at the aim of making things easier for humans.
我们大脑工作效率的技术时，难道我们不会只是简单地利用剩余的时间去做更多的事情吗？我认为这完全正确。在这个领域和整个控制论中存在一场辩论。我们真的应该做这些事情吗？这对人类或个人真的有帮助吗？我的感觉是，我们一直在取得技术进步，它们的目标一直是为了让人们的生活更轻松。
And I also think that you have a choice. You can choose to use these tools to make you more efficient and then go on a hike or a walk. Or you can choose to use these tools to make you more efficient and then you go do more work. That is a personal choice that I think everyone has to make. We were just talking with Kal Newport. He's a professor of computer science at Georgetown University and he's the author of a new book that looks at Deepwork, the idea that we are doing too many things and the way to actually be less busy
而且我也认为你有选择权。你可以选择使用这些工具让你更有效率，然后去徒步旅行或散步。或者你可以选择使用这些工具让你更有效率，然后去做更多的工作。这是一个我认为每个人都必须做出的个人选择。我们刚才在和卡尔·纽波特交谈。他是乔治城大学的计算机科学教授，也是一本新书的作者，该书着眼于深度工作，即我们正在做太多的事情，而实际上减少忙碌的方法
and to be more focused is actually just to be less busy, to take on fewer things, to say no to many more things and to carve out time where we can actually stay and focus on things. And I'm wondering what he would say to this kind of intervention. And I think he would say, you're trying to find sort of a technical solution to what is really a human behavior problem. And the technical solution is, let's make the brain 5% better than it was before. But of course, when you do that, you're just going to take on 10% more work. Yeah. I personally don't think that TDCS should be used in somebody's everyday life.
并且更专注实际上只是减少忙碌，承担更少的事情，对更多的事情说不，并留出时间，我们可以真正留下来专注于事情。我想知道他会对这种干预说些什么。我想他会说，你试图为真正的人类行为问题找到一种技术解决方案。而技术解决方案是，让我们的大脑比以前好5%。但当然，当你这样做时，你只会承担10%更多的工作。是的。我个人认为TDCS不应该用于某人的日常生活中。
It should be used as a tool to look at the underlying physiological process. So I don't think that everybody should have a helmet that has this. It's like cheating. And so what really needs to be done is have people out in the forefront who understand these issues and then they can present it to the general public in a way that makes sense. So yes, we have this ability to change the, you know, neural functioning of your brain
它应该被用作观察潜在生理过程的工具。所以我认为并不是每个人都应该有一个带有这个的头盔。这就像作弊。所以真正需要做的是让那些了解这些问题的人站在最前沿，然后他们可以以一种有意义的方式将其呈现给公众。所以是的，我们有这种能力改变，你知道，你大脑的神经功能
within a few minutes, but here's how and why we should use that and here's how we shouldn't use that and really have a lot of thought put into it for introducing these things into the public. Hmm, cause in some ways I'm wondering, you know, that what we lack is not sort of our ability to multitask, but our ability to actually sit with things. Really, I think that is a more like cultural and societal issue that we have. So, you know, I know some people who are really
在几分钟内，但这就是我们应该如何以及为什么使用它，以及我们不应该如何使用它，并在将这些东西引入公众之前真正投入大量思考。嗯，因为在某些方面我想知道，你知道，我们缺乏的不是我们多任务处理的能力，而是我们真正与事物共处的能力。真的，我认为这更像是一个我们面临的文化和社会问题。所以，你知道，我认识一些人，他们真的
good at saying, no, I just don't want to do that. And then I know the people who would never say no to an opportunity, even though it means more work. And as a graduate student, I can fully attest to that. And I'm sure, I'll help you out, I'll do this. I don't need to sleep, it's fine. I've been in the gym in six months. And so I think that's more of a cultural thing and needs to be something that's addressed. And that people in technology, sectors, or in science,
擅长说，不，我只是不想做那个。然后我认识那些永远不会对机会说不的人，即使这意味着更多的工作。作为一名研究生，我可以完全证明这一点。而且我肯定，我会帮你，我会做这个。我不需要睡觉，没关系。我六个月没去健身房了。所以我认为这更多的是一种文化现象，需要被解决。而且人们在技术、部门或科学领域，
if we allow them to go on a hike and a walk, that's been shown to give you these aha moments and actually help your cognition. And so if we change the way we thought about it that way, where yes, we're going to make this more efficient, but that rest of the time is yours instead of, or to make this more efficient, and that time is still mine. That would be my ultimate solution. Each year, we learn a whole lot more about how the brain works. In the future, maybe we will have helmets
如果我们允许他们去徒步旅行和散步，这已被证明能给你带来这些顿悟时刻，并实际上帮助你的认知。所以如果我们以那种方式改变我们的想法，即是的，我们要让这个更有效率，但剩下的时间是你的，而不是，或者让这个更有效率，而那个时间仍然是我的。那将是我的终极解决方案。每年，我们对大脑的工作方式了解得更多。将来，也许我们会有头盔
that we can wear at work. They'll allow us to be more focused or juggle multiple demands. There's nothing wrong with trying to get the most out of our brains, any more than there's something wrong and trying to get the most out of our legs or our hands. If there are machines that can help us lift heavier things than we ever thought possible and machines that can help us move faster than we ever imagined, there are certainly going to be machines
我们可以在工作中佩戴。它们将允许我们更专注或处理多种需求。试图从我们的大脑中获得最大收益并没有什么错，就像试图从我们的腿或手中获得最大收益并没有什么错一样。如果有机器可以帮助我们举起比我们想象中更重的东西，有机器可以帮助我们比我们想象中移动得更快，那么肯定会有机器
one day to help us think faster or more clearly. In fact, you could argue this is exactly what an education does. You spend years in school or hours reading books or listening to a radio show like this one, to improve how your brain works. But in the end, technology is just a tool. We need wisdom to know how to use it. A helmet or a phone can't tell you if it's a good idea to push your brain to work twice as fast, or if working too hard might make you unhappy.
有一天帮助我们思考得更快或更清晰。事实上，你可以说这正是教育所做的。你在学校里花几年时间，或者花几个小时读书，或者听像这样的广播节目，来改善你的大脑工作方式。但最终，技术只是一个工具。我们需要智慧来知道如何使用它。头盔或手机无法告诉你强迫你的大脑工作两倍快是否是个好主意，或者工作太努力是否会让你不快乐。
For those answers, you need that leg side retreat, or at least a quiet walk in the woods. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Ye Lee. Ye is a partner manager at Spotify and has helped us to brainstorm ways to connect new listeners to Hidden Brain. He always has great suggestions for how we can engage more deeply with our audience and is really hardworking and kind.
对于这些答案，你需要那个湖畔静修处，或者至少在树林里安静地散步。“隐藏大脑”由“隐藏大脑”媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯汀·王、奥特姆·巴恩斯、瑞安·卡茨和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏大脑”的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是叶李。叶是Spotify的合作伙伴经理，并帮助我们集思广益，寻找将新听众与“隐藏大脑”联系起来的方法。他总是对我们如何与观众进行更深层次的互动有很好的建议，而且非常勤奋和善良。
We are so glad we get to work with him. Thank you, Yi. Coming up next week on our Work 2.0 series, we delve into the minds of successful rule breakers. Rebels are people who break rules that should be broken. They break rules that hold them and others back, and their way of rule breaking is constructive rather than destructive. It creates positive change.
我们很高兴能与他共事。谢谢你，叶。下周在我们的“工作2.0”系列节目中，我们将深入探讨成功规则破坏者的思想。叛逆者是打破应该被打破的规则的人。他们打破了阻碍他们和其他人的规则，他们的规则破坏方式是建设性的而不是破坏性的。它创造了积极的改变。
One last request from me before we go. If you like Hidden Brain, be sure to check out our new podcast, My Unsung Hero. Each week we hear from a person who has helped in a moment of crisis by an unsung hero, often a stranger. Every episode is short, about 5 minutes, and it will make you feel better about the world. If you like the show, please subscribe and tell a friend about it. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们离开之前，我还有一个请求。如果你喜欢“隐藏大脑”，一定要看看我们的新播客“我的无名英雄”。每周我们都会听到一个在危机时刻得到无名英雄（通常是陌生人）帮助的人的故事。每一集都很短，大约5分钟，它会让你对这个世界感觉更好。如果你喜欢这个节目，请订阅并告诉你的朋友。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。